Lauren, hey, what're you, what're you doing?
>> All that talk of mutations is really sobering, so
I just kind of came out here to relax and sunbathe.
>> Yeah, but you realize sunlight causes all kinds of mutations, right?
>> Matt, I can't get away from you. What are you talking about?
>> Of course, like UV light from the sun is a
major source of induced mutations. There's UVA, UVB rays from the
sun. They directly cause mutations and can cause other molecules to
indirectly cause mutations. In fact, if you've ever had a, a sunburn
before where your skin cells turn red and then
peel off. It's because you got so many mutations
that your body couldn't fix them all, and so
they committed self-suicide to save you from skin cancer.
>> It's a good thing that I wore sunscreen today, but
I really wish my skin would just protect itself on its own.
>> Well, there's actually a mechanism
for that. It's actually skin pigmentation.
>> So you say if I had darker skin
tone, I wouldn't be so susceptible to skin cancer?
>> Exactly. Let's, let's go learn a bit more
about how that works. Okay.